dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir today we will
listen to a new AI from deep mind that
is capable of creating beautiful piano
music because there are many algorithms
that do that to put things into
perspective let's talk about the two key
differentiating factors that set this
method apart from previously existing
techniques one music is typically
learned from high-level representations
such as the score or MIDI data this is a
precise representation of what needs to
be played but they don't tell us how to
play them
these small nuances are what makes the
music come alive and this is exactly
what is missing from most of the
synthesis techniques this new method is
able to learn these structures and
generates not midi signals but raw audio
waveforms and - it is better at
retaining stylistic consistency most
previous techniques create music that is
consistent on a shorter time scale but
to not take into consideration what was
played 30 seconds ago and therefore they
elect a high level structure that is the
hallmark of quality songwriting however
this new method shows stylistic
consistency over long time periods let's
give it a quick listen and talk about
the architecture of this learning
algorithm after that while we listen
I'll show you the composer's it has
learned from to produce this
[Music]
I have never heard any AI generated
music before with such articulation and
the harmonies are also absolutely
amazing truly stunning results it uses
an architecture that goes by the name
auto regressive discrete auto encoder
this contains an encoder module that
takes a raw audio waveform and
compresses it down into an internal
representation where the encoder part is
responsible for reconstructing the raw
audio from this internal representation
both of them are neural networks the
autoregressive part means that the
algorithm looks at previous time steps
in the learned audio signals when
producing new notes and is implemented
in the egg holder module essentially
this is what gives the algorithm longer
term memory to remember what it played
earlier as you have seen the data set
the algorithm learned from as the music
was playing I am also really curious how
we can exert artistic control over the
output by changing the data set
essentially you can likely change what
the student learns by changing the
textbooks used to teach them for now
let's marvel at one more sound sample
[Music]
this is already incredible and I can
only imagine what we will be able to do
not ten years from now just a year from
now thanks for watching and for your
generous support now see you next time